I don't know if it's brilliant but
thanks yeah so I had this talk prepared
and then last night just before going to
bed I was thinking about all the great
talks that we heard yesterday and it had
some idea inspired by the talks
yesterday and I think I much rather tell
you about that gets much more
interesting result and what I had
planned to do so there's a risk that
there's a buck and someone will find it
and I promise beer if someone finds a
book and then this would be a little bit
embarrassing but I think with the
audience here is much more interesting
resort to tell you about them what I had
planned to do so this is a little bit
improvised and not prepared at all but
let's try it okay so what I'll be
talking about is of course conditioning
lower bounds and so from the talks
yesterday sort of clear they've met all
these different conjectures that you
could use to prove lower bounds ask this
the community are abuddin matrix
multiplication conjecture yes sir Seth
and 3some and say a PSP and you also
each of these conjectures we use to
prove lower bounds for different
problems right and it sounded like we
even needed to have even more
conjectures to capture all of P right
that was sort of the impression I got
from mes talk so what I was trying to
think about is if some of these
conjectures implied otherwise it seems
like a natural question and I think
other people have been looking at that
and that's not exactly what I managed to
think i managed to show but so the
result is here so if emm is true so comm
unit or boolean matrix multiplication
requires into the three- little o of one
time then there's no end to the three
half minus epsilon three sum algorithm
and i want to say combinatorial okay so
these if it's true there's some progress
towards unifying some of these
conjectures okay so if there's no
community are going to make some
application heirloom running in into the
three minus C then there's no threesome
algorithm that's combinatorial it runs
an end to the three half minus Epsilon I
don't cover the conjecture for three
summers N squared this this is off
interesting thing is that the decision
tree complexity of 3some is in fact or
fin two three half as was shown by Seth
and Ellen Fox last year I think so you
know maybe maybe in squares not the
right answer I don't know but at least
this show that there's some connection
between the problems and I think this
was more interesting than what I had to
tell you about otherwise I so this is
like the first implication i think the
second one this just want my implication
of this stuff which is not quite as
interesting as this this one but the
second one is under the same assumption
chromatog will make you some lubrication
is true and there's no into three half
minus epsilon three orthogonal vectors
let's combinatorial through your thermal
vectors so this problem has n cubed
conjecture complexity so this is not as
interesting at the other one but at
least it shows some connection so I try
to see if I can convince you about that
and myself and I'll start with this one
over here okay so let me move over here
okay so just to summarize the problem
right so from a solid major publication
we have these two boolean matrices that
n by M and we want to compute the
product and so for this talk I think
about it as since this is not a vector
but this is not a matrix but essentially
you have n vectors for which you want to
compute mb ok so this is m and you have
vectors we won to vm you want to compute
each of these matrix vector product
which is obviously the same problem ok
it's just a little bit easier to think
about
so the first step of this reduction is
inspired by the nice paper by monica
hint singer and co-authors where they
introduced this online a matrix-vector
problem from that problem they have this
online matrix-vector problem you have
the matrix that we make sure you vectors
arrive one at a time and you have to
output MV before seeing the next Victor
is one of the steps they used in that
paper to prove condition lower bound was
that they first reduced this problem to
another problem where you have is you
have vector paths ok so we have a matrix
M then you see passive exit so you see
you want v1 you get in pairs if we'd
spare you're supposed to output whether
you are supposed to output you I
transpose mvi so this is just a number
this time sort of the interpretation of
this is if you think of the matrix m you
I selects a subset of the Rose the Rose
for which this is one entry in in you VI
selects the subset of the columns and
you're basically asking whether this sub
matrix that's induced by these rows and
columns has a one in it that's exactly
the question you're answering is the one
inside any of these entries
so they're reduction this isn't the
online setting so these pairs the right
one at a time so then we spatially show
that if you can do this and in 2 3 minus
C then you can do this and I think it's
like n to the 3-0 1 plus to see you
sometimes ok so for boolean matrix
multiplication up here we know all the
vectors at the same time I have all the
vectors available and so basically the
first step is to redo the reduction and
show that you can reduce to the case
where you know all the vector pass at
the same time space you're just going
over there a reduction little bit of
care and you can sort of do the same
thing right so you can show that given
all these pairs at the same time if you
can answer these vector matrix vector
products fat in into the 3 minus C time
then you can solve Buddha make some
green case in them to the 3 minus c uo 1
plus 2c i think i'll show you over the
direction at the end but it's basically
just the same as they do so i'll get
back to that at the end more interesting
part is then how do we solve this
problem using threesome right so that's
a interesting part the new part so let's
try to have a look
okay so yeah so the first observation
this entity which was inspired by wanted
to talk yesterday is that if you look at
so now I have this matrix and I'm
looking at just one of these answering
one of these pairs you think about is
that if you think of having a graph has
one note per row of em and one note per
column of them this query over here this
question that you're answering all right
so if you pick everyone entering this
matrix so let's say in row I and come j
and you draw an edge between the i'th
node over here and the jf node up there
what you're asking is really maybe I
should take another color for these
queries it just selects a subset of the
notes over here a subset of the nodes up
here and then you're asking whether the
induced sub graph has an edge or not
that's the question you're answering
which is what's we talked about
yesterday and so what's we and Seth sure
was that this problem is threesome hot
okay just 3sum hard to report the
induced sub graph under some setting of
parameters here we basically want to
reverse it this reduction which is was
inspired by what Emmanuel was doing
yesterday so he basically spawned a way
to list triangles if you had an element
for threesome so that's basically wants
to do here so the first idea so let me
just show you at the idea if you're just
answering one of these queries the idea
is so let's first pick a hash function
essentially what a man well did it
hatches these nodes of this graph to
some big polynomial universe let's say n
to the 10 okay and now what you can do
is to take each edge here the states
between algorithms we called them s and
T these two end points
so you take this edge each edges turn
into a number in your 3some instance
okay and the number that you generate is
the hash of s plus the house of tea okay
and so the version of reason that I'll
be looking at is this you have three
sets you have a you have B and you have
the sunset and you're looking from one
in a and 1 in B that sums to 1 and s
okay so that's the version we're looking
at so basically all the edges here would
be the subset and there will be of the
form or there'll be one number of page
and we'll have this form ok now when one
of these you you is be ice arrived into
it what we want to do is we take all the
numbers that are in my setup notes over
here then I just pick your just add to a
is just the hash of all these numbers
all these notes that's in my set right
and up here similarly for be I just
include the hash of all the nodes that
are in my set then they get us set a I
said be and the sunset okay so what's
the observation so if there is an edge
in this induced sub graph the hash of
the one endpoint isn't a the heads of
the other endpoint is in B and because
the edge is there the sum of the hashes
is also an S right so there isn't a
solution to the 3some instance now the
second idea is basically cut these hash
values this hash functions maps to say n
to the 10 let's say that's for wise
independent or something like this then
you won't have any false collisions with
probability when I say 1 minus 1 over N
to the 5th or something like this do you
believe this or should be but what I
don't understand is the service is going
to be yeah it's going to be his n square
and yosef size m that's right yeah so
that's the next this is just if you had
only won you AI and bi right so now I'm
going to try to solve it for all these
pairs at the same time so that's the
next step right this is just the
intuition if I had only one you I + 1 VI
that I was trying to solve it for and
this is why this stuff does not work the
online matrix
vector problem the only works for the
boolean matrix and education okay
alright so now we have something at
least if I only had one you and VI I get
a set here that has size n and this
would have size n and this would have
size n square right so the N squared yes
the problem gets too big compared to the
two other sets so what we want to do is
basically we want to do all these in
parallel all these pairs in parallel
okay and so for this today I have
another hash function G and what it does
is it basically maps an index from one
to n so this is something from 1m it
also maps it to some really big range
this is it into the 10 ok now what I
conception to do is for each of these
paths imagine you have a copy of all
these notes ok so this is so this is
like thee for the I've pair this is for
the eyes prepare have a copy of all the
notes and just letting a subset of them
so basically it's call so the version of
them so you had a note s for row here
you have a DI copy of this s it won't
have the it won't turn into the number
hash of this but it will turn into the
hash of s plus G of I so I have to add
some part of the hash function that
tells me which pair I come from ok and
so the same over here so the one that
comes from the ice-sub problem the I've
vector pair i instead of doing hash of
tea I do hash of t minus G of I ok so
what happens now is if one of these
pairs has the answer one there is an
edge in one of these pairs then this
will have a solution right so let's say
the I've pair has a one in the sub
matrix you basically just go into maybe
let's say that corresponds to the node s
and then OT and the there's an HST in
there maybe what you observe is that the
GIS cancel out because it's the same sub
problem that you're looking at and then
you still have the same that the heads
of s plus the hash of T sums to the
swing in here so what we've done now is
this an ok so the G is so we again we
have to worry about false positives so
could you get false positives in this
thing and base what we observe is that
if you try to add an um if you try to
use a note from two different
subproblems two different vector pairs
the GI and the GJ will be independent
and they'll has to something random that
won't hit with high probability so
that's the intuition here so what we can
do now is basically we can take this you
take the three sum algorithm what's the
size of the inputs now right we have in
pairs so now a has size n squared be a
size N squared and exercise n square now
they have the right sizes so if 3some
runs in into the three half minus
epsilon what you do now to answering
this instance now takes into the 3-2 see
time if 3some is an end to the three
half minus C right because the input
size is n squared you're looking for a
bound that sub cubic to solve this
problem so if 3somes inches we have
minus c you get sub cubic
there's still one problem with this
reduction up to now what we get out now
is just basically just told the are of
all these answers right if one of them
has a one there will be a 3some inch
there will be the answer will be yes to
the threesome problem and otherwise if
none of them has a 12 B know but we have
to answer all of these pairs so
answering all the pair's is the next
step and it just uses some of the ideas
that has appeared before and in many of
these reductions so basically want to
base the idea is that if you you know
okay so you can change the three sum
algorithm so let's say if there is a
threesome you can also find a witness
efficiently all right so this is not too
difficult probably also saw it in the
meta manuel's talk yesterday so
basically you can do is you can petition
a into two equal size set B into two
equal size sets and s into two equal
size steps try all eight combinations if
one of them one of them must have the
answer yes and you just recurse on that
one until you down to finding a witness
because we can find the witness in the
same running time because this cell
problem sizes all go also go down by a
constant vector as you can find a
witness in the same running time it is
clear enough so you can find a witness
so the problem is still right so you
find a witness over here maybe not now
you know that the pair you I VI has the
answer one so you pay intuitive you can
remove it and just continue in the
remaining n minus one pass this will
take you too long right because you need
to do it n times to solve all these
pairs so since it's too expensive to
find a witness and remove one of these
pairs so somehow we need to do something
that we can find all these witnesses and
not make it as expensive to find the
witnesses and this just uses some of the
ideas that appear in in other work so we
just want to decrease the cost of
finding a witness the idea here is take
your matrix them
and now you partition it into a K by K
grid so basically you have n over K by n
over K sub matrices and now the
intuition is that you just solve on all
these sub matrices one of the time is it
what does that mean so so now basically
had all these so this was a d1 the N and
you had the columns rows over here you
have u 1 u 2 m and now what you do is
you start by looking this first sub
matrix up here so you're looking for
witnesses inside the sub matrix now so
you're looking for witnesses inside the
sub matrix so this is an n over K by n
over K sub matrix we already show we can
find a witness in n to the 3-2 see time
where n is the size of the matrix if you
have equal sized the number of vector
pairs is equal to the number of rows and
columns situation is you start with the
first sub matrix as you just cut these
into pairs of groups of n over K vectors
each you just handle each of these
groups on this smaller instance one of
the time ok so now you have this group
here you have n over K row vectors in RK
column vectors and if you're in the sub
matrix up here basically what you're
using is only the first n over K
coordinates of each of these vectors
right and the first n over K coordinates
of each of these vectors right it's the
same exact same problem that you're
looking for once inside this sub matrix
up here
okay so now we just do that using the
threesome algorithm and find the witness
it isn't as if we find a witness now we
just remove the pair bi you I that
costed witness to appear and we just do
it again with the remaining vectors in
the set until there are no more
witnesses we do that for all the vectors
then all the ones that haven't we
haven't found a witness for just move on
to the next sub matrix move on to the
next one and the next one the next one
give this solves the problem right so
the question is just how much time does
it cost to do it like this okay now we
need to argue that it's not too
expensive when we do this so let's try
to argue that so right we already agreed
that if we can solve threesome
efficiently then we can solve this
problem in into the 3-2 see time on an
inn by n matrix with invictus you see
what happens now
so for each of these sub matrices you
have basically we do it you have n
vectors that you need to go over to K
times that you need to solve this
subproblem of n over K by n over K by n
over K right on each of these sub
matrices and so solving also the first
run with a batch of n over K vectors
then over K vectors with the sub matrix
so you have one run at least for each of
these groups and so how many of these
execution what is all these execution
costs so right we have K squared sub
matrices we have K groups of vectors
will be solving on this sub matrix and
solving a group cast n over K to the
three minus C time- to see the same okay
so this is the cost of the first run
inside a sub matrix first time that
you've done it for the thing was that
whenever we found a witness we have to
repeat right now you found a witness
where to repeat on the same set of
vectors so I says you should we get a
lot of repetitions runnings of the
algorithm again and so what does that
cost so the observation is now this can
only happen in x right because once you
found a witness you remove the vector
pair you know the answers 1 so maybe you
have in total over the entire matrix you
have n of those runs where you pay again
n over K to the 3 minus C time to do the
run now we balance the two terms to
figure out what we should ship k 2 and
so what does this give yeah so basically
have to set K to the end to the 103
right
and so what is the running time that we
get drop this in so then you get n times
into the two-thirds to the three- see
this one here is into the 2-2 3c times
an M so basically a sub cubic now right
so that's good solving all these
subproblems in total cost sub cubic time
so I guess the only thing left to do now
is the first reduction from boolean mesa
munication to this fetched let's call it
batch vector matrix vector
multiplication just people want to hear
this that we all know the pump and
tensing adèle do it for completeness
okay right so the only step missing is
this from this version to to this
version maybe yeah let's do that now so
the idea is sort of similar so again you
you take your matrix m you divide it
into AK by K grid and now suppose you
had all these n vectors that you're
trying to compute the inner products
rather than the matrix vector product
and when you do is you zoom in on one
row we call this like call this a super
row so this all this up here this is a
super row it has n over K axl rose and
so now look at what were we doing it in
for a super row so the idea here is that
so let's again so this is a sub problem
of size n over K by n over K and so now
you group your vectors again in two
batches of inner ok vectors to get the
sizes to match
and now the idea the really beautiful
idea of fencing I doubt is that you so
inside this subproblem here you want to
use this vexes you for something but
you'll be using the use for is so you
want if you want to figure out which of
these inner products these nkk inner
products are one right and so to the
ideas today you have the first batch of
n over K vectors you want to figure out
which is the inner products are one when
you just live with this sub matrix here
so this is the first part of the vectors
against this sub matrix in here when you
start by doing is that you take so for
each of these n over K vectors you
create a corresponding u vector this is
this call this v12 BN o ok so you create
you one to you and ok initially these
are all once vectors is they're all ones
vectors and now so the observation is
that now if i run this benched a vector
matrix vector algorithm on these n over
K pairs against this in ok by n over K
matrix I'll be told which of these pairs
have since the UI transpose this tiny
matrix that's called m11 with the VI so
i'll be told all of these products they
have been told for each one of them if
there's at least one of the rows in this
sub matrix that has the inner product
one with my set of current vectors right
which of them I'll be told whether
there's one of these row inner products
that's one the idea is then you search
for witnesses again so once you take
this group you run this query against
the sub matrix and you'll be told which
subset of them that has an inner product
of one with the least one of the rows in
the sub matrix and your ears so you take
the ones that does have such an inner
product then you want to search for
witness
and this is what you'll use the U vector
for to search for a witness so the idea
is if you take all these inner work so
there's some at most n over K vectors
here that have some inner part of one in
here what you do is each of them has a
corresponding u vector basically a nice
you vectors have a bunch of ones which
is essentially selecting the subset of
rows that you're whoring over so we each
of them you just arbitrarily petition
the U vector into two halves equal size
and now you run both of these batched
matrix vector vector matrix queries for
the way you've set all of them to the
first half of their choice of one's into
the second half of the choice of one's
then you'll have learned for each of
them you'll have learned one of the
halves in which there's a witness right
this is here enough or should I repeat
it again so essentially each of these
ones is a selecting a subset of rows
that we're oaring over and so for one of
these you is arbitrarily partition these
one bits into two halves at the same
time for all of these n over K vectors I
just choose the first half of all of
them and i run this batch vector matrix
vector query that will tell me which of
them that inside the selected half of of
the ones actually has a witness right
now we are in over only half the number
of rows and will be told if there's a
witness still essentially we learn for
each of these in over K vectors we learn
which half has a witness maybe both of
them have but we learn at least one of
the half that has a witness and then we
do this login times to find the witness
for each of them right so we find a
witness which means essentially we've
discovered for each of these vectors
that had some inner product of one in
this sub matrix we discover a row that
has the inner product one then the nice
idea that you do is essentially you just
erase that one bit from you you go back
to the you you had before the binary
search and you erase that one bit
means now you're not searching over that
bit anymore and now do you need a little
bit of more care to to get it to work
probably here so the idea is when you're
solving this sub problem here is they
take these n vectors that you get in and
petition them into groups based on how
many ones they have found so far alright
so that's only n over K rows here so
there will be n over K groups the
potential of or whatever of these
vectors so there's a group where you
found where you still can find up to n
over K things and then all the way down
to this it's not possible to find any
more once in the sub matrix so you
haven't so incensed your n vectors you
start by partitioning them into groups
when you get to this sub matrix based on
how many ones it can how many witnesses
you can find in total when you wobble
with this row and so then the idea is a
little bit more refined you start by
taking the larger of these groups
petition in two batches of n over K
vectors and search for witnesses for the
ones that have a witness in here you
update the you by erasing the
corresponding coordinate and then you
move them down to the next we can call a
potential group right so you know now
you found a witness so that's now the
third most in ok minus one more times
you can find a witness while going over
this entire super super bro right this
is fatally what's going on right you can
the most find a witness in over K times
throughout the entire super room because
once you've found a witness you know
already that you don't have to look in
here to figure out what the inner
product is because this part over here
already told you let the enterprise one
and so that's the whole idea so you just
start from the first block in this super
row you find witnesses and the ones that
have them you move them to the next
potential group you take the next group
and do it again so you need to make sure
that they're not more rows you one of
these vectors could have in a part of
one with many of the rows right so you
so once you've dealt with the first
group of
potential to take the next one you move
the ones down that actually where you
found the witness you take the next
group and so forth all the way insulate
eventually end up in the last group if
they ever do so right so once you've
done that for the sub matrix and there
are no more witnesses left you just move
on to the next one in this Subaru the
next matrix and you keep the use because
you know it's Italy the same row that
you're trying to figure out what the
inner products are is the same set of
rows when you're in a super room so
basically that's what's going on right
so essentially throughout an entire
super row you can be it you can find the
witness at most n over K times and so
that's the main idea for lowering the
cost for finding these witnesses is you
group into these micro matrices and then
just scan over the row again so the same
as basically the same as we saw before
just a little bit more clever this
reduction here and so essentially you
just do the math set K to be square root
n and and you get the right round just
count how many times does this happen
and and so forth it's the same as for
stunning in the other paper all right so
that basically shows that this is and
this is a combinatorial reduction so
let's see interesting part so if you can
do three summon into the three half
minus epsilon commits early then you can
solve boolean matrix multiplication in
into the three months or phipps Omega
epsilon a community right so I think the
last one I wanted to mention was this
connection to three orthogonal vectors
it's sort of interesting too so
basically what we want to do is we want
to use it since we want to again use
three orthogonal vectors to solve this
figuring out whether there's a niche in
this collection of induced subgraphs
it's the same exact same problem and we
can solve it into the three half minus
epsilon we can do the same reduction all
right so we have this matrix and you
have some notes and two notes have some
edges and the queries is again n sub
sets over here and subsets over here
that come in pairs and you want to know
if one of these pairs has an edge in
them and then we just redo the rest of
the reduction if we can solve this one
in in better than n cubed time this way
if you want to do this using a three
orthogonal vector so maybe I should
define the problem so three orthogonal
vectors is another one you do get from
Seth basically by petitioning your
variables into three groups and doing
all combinations of three doing all
combinations and then you're looking for
as you have three sets let's call them a
B and C this time you're looking for a
vector in a veteran be and a vacancy so
that the end the bitwise end of these
vectors is zero excellence if you have a
bitwise end of a B and C should be the 0
and this is this requires in cube time
under safe so this the lower bound will
get here is not a strong but I need to
relate the two problems
nice wet so now I want to essentially
use a solution for three orthogonal
vectors to figure out and these one of
if one of these induced subgraphs has a
as an edge in them and so the idea is
the same as before since you had these n
copies of your rows and n copies of your
columns and you have the edges in the
middle you have n squared edges in the
middle and so what you do is so for an
edge between S&T you create a bit
pattern and so the first half of the
pattern will be basically s written in
binary followed by is a bitwise
complement in binary and then you duty
and you do t bitwise complement and then
you do all once this is what you do for
all the edges in the middle sister okay
so now you go so what do you do with the
eyes copy of an s of X is so what you do
is go over here so basically write s
complement is right all once and now you
ride I I complement a lotta white works
at the end and finally up here if you do
for the TI
do is you have we have all once in the
beginning now you write T compliment t
and you ride I compliment I ok so what's
the idea here of this construction so
basically want to argue this that
whenever I select an edge whenever it's
select the triple they can only be a
thumbnail if the SI and the ti come from
the same I so maybe they have the same I
as I may only use this one induced sub
graph and this is what the last part is
yours this part the end of these three
things is the end of these guys and this
will only be zero exactly these
compliments use the complements of each
other both cases right that's the idea
these two will be serial needs to be 0
and this will not be the case if there
was not an index okay so you know so
this makes sure that I can know if I
want enough top of the pair i can only
use an SI a TI that came from the same
sub problem and the last part is so i
want to use an edge as well and then
here you can see essentially the same
trick i can only use an edge to get on a
thousand pair if the S aligns with the s
and the te matches the tea that's the
only way they would be orthogonal and so
that's the full proof here you have an
authority if and only if one of these
and subproblems has an edge and so the
size of these bit patterns here right so
this n nodes here in each of these
copies this is log n bits this is log n
bits log in bits and log in bits yeah
and log in bits along its so essentially
there's six log in bits holding these
vectors and the instant sizes so n is
basically N squared what you really
shown to the supper of this is an
instance of three automakers of size N
squared so really the dimension is three
log n ub scale the problem size so i
think it's also interesting to get such
as fixed constant to show any hardness
that you you actually under the comments
are gonna make some lubrication
conjecture you can't do into the three
half
minus epsilon if d is equal 3 log in and
you believe the comments are boolean
matrix communication conjecture this is
sort of a very tight bound on when the
size of the vectors so I think that
pretty much that's what I wanted to say
hope I convinced you yeah I don't know
how will I be able to answer questions
please try okay that's good because I
mean the first result about BMN reason
this is no yeah actually but actually
I've never seen it playing this way
before it's such an excellent
presentation thanks so much yeah let's
go ahead it showed me is very natural
what could be the dramatic consequences
because you the last trip is just two
vectors what I'm sure that is the flyer
just come see me oh if you if this was
not three orthogonal vectors but too
well I guess then you would get a lower
bound of into three half or orthogonal
vectors the normal version of the
problem still not n squared low bond but
an end to three half lower bound I don't
tell you yeah I guess you can actually
do better in this yeah i guess i guess
that there's a reason why I fails
listen